each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available good morning everybody it's a
real pleasure to have here with us
Stefan stop from the University of
coblan Dow in Germany uh Stefan is um
Professor for databases and information
systems and uh he's uh cited among the
top top 10 researchers at dab dab dab
and the semantic and the semantic web
conferences and uh today he's going to
talk about some work that uh we've been
working on with um Don SIM from
Microsoft research Cambridge on uh
actually using some semantic
Technologies um to help make sense of
data but more broadly Stefan has been
working also on using semantic
Technologies uh to support software
modeling and uh I want talk about what
we've been doing and what Stefan has
been doing with his um team because he's
just going to talk about it I just
mentioned that we came back from popo um
like couple of days ago uh where we had
a workshop on data Centric programming
and where there was a lot of interest
actually into these approaches of
bringing um more toolin to help
developers make sense of data so with
that Stefan please thank you very much
for your kind introduction Evelyn so um
the work I talk about um includes a
couple of people from uh my team was
initiated actually by Evelyn and uh don
to look at how can we bring some of the
semantic web technology semantic web
data structures into
FP and uh um among the people from my
team there is Martin linberger he's PhD
student in our team and he's also there
then to later on show you some demo
because I must frankly con confess I'm a
little bit too far away from the code
base really to to show this in a
competent manner okay so our Point of
Departure is this uh quite famous
picture uh from the uh linked open data
Cloud um for those who have not seen it
maybe who of you have seen it before I
guess many will have no not so many okay
so what does it symbolize each of these
bubbles stands for a data source and uh
then some colleagues from Manheim Chris
Biser and his team they have collected
how these different data sources each
one of these bubbles has hundreds of
thousands or or millions of triples of
facts and how each of these data sources
is connected to other data sources
following the semantic web paradigm okay
many of them are connected to dbpedia
and dedia is the the fact base derived
from Wikipedia right so stuff that
drives also on Knowledge Graph and other
kind of approaches and the interesting
thing about this is that it's like like
the web but not on a document base but
on a fact base and what is also
interesting is that this
data has a lot of different data
structures a lot of different schema
well and some of that has actually very
little SCH in just the facts so it's
very heterogeneous and by now it also is
actually more than 30 billion RF triples
and even some famous database
researchers here for example G wcom in
Sigma block says this is I actually a
nice kind of um environment to try your
approaches if you deal with
heterogeneous data and if you think of
Big Data not only in terms of having
massive amounts of uh a simple schema
instead iation but if you think in terms
of having a lot of variety of data so I
will use this as a kind of motivation
for my talk though um it's very clear
when I talk about understanding new data
sources that come in it need not be this
kind of Link data that so many people
look at it could also be just your
relational data source that you
encounter where you don't know the
schema and that you have to deal
with so when we look at these different
bubbles each one representing an
individual data source with millions of
facts you see that when you look at them
in detail you have very different
domains for example here you have stuff
about pbet for example so from the
medical domain or drug Bank Gene onology
this kind of thing then here you have um
a kind of column which is about
publications from the ICM or from the
dblp server which provides you a
bibliography or from here's our partner
the LA Institute for social Sciences uh
with whom we co collaborate very closely
they look at publishing metadata and all
kinds of data about uh scientific
literature in the social sciences here
you have stuff about uh geographical
information here you have stuff New York
Times is publishing a lot of uh linked
data about the Articles they have uh
just putting them on the web and making
them accessible uh BBC is doing the same
kind of thing so you have this media
domain uh which is very active and then
you have like these generic data bases
fact bases like dbpedia but also like
free base which actually part of Google
or like Yago which was done by wum and
his
team when I talk about a few more of the
foundations of the semantic web I have
to explain to you uh the very simple
Foundation that we have there what is
this very simple Foundation we talk
about data and data for us is simply
that you have some subject and each
object or here this particular subject
is represented by a URI a UR is nothing
else than a globally unique identifier
so with this globally unique identifier
you can take this identifier and ask for
please give me more information about
you okay and if such subjects are
related via a specific predicate to an
object this object can be another URI it
could also be just like a string or an
integer and that's the very simple data
model behind rdf so extremely simplistic
much poorer than relational databases
but at the same time like a common
denominator for publishing data and for
this piece of data you can describe a
schema and that schema has classes and
it can have class
hierarchies you will see a very trivial
example from me uh on the next slide and
you can describe how different classes
are connected by predicates and the
predicate has a certain domain
constraint and a certain range
constraint ad if is very simple you
don't even have cardinalities if you
want to bring them in you need to have a
more sophisticated standard which is
called Owl for the web ontology
language okay here is a very simple
example a little bit trivial but I think
nice enough to tell you the story uh so
what is the example here RF resource is
like the kind of top class that includes
everything and then you have a subclass
like creature all these Uris they come
with Nam spaces as you know them from
XML uh so you can really distinguish
let's say a creature that I describe in
my examples or a creature as it would be
described in some biology domain or in
some other domain as you like and we
always abbreviate them here just to make
it more readable but you could mix them
completely you could take some Uris that
coming from the Microsoft domain with
some biology domain with my exams you
could mix them all together in a giant
Global
graph and here for this class creature
you have several subclasses like like
dog or person and you have attributes
described like has name and has age and
we could continue here to describe what
are the range constraints for example
that the name would come as a string or
that age would come as an
integer we have left it out of the
picture here and then here you see
another example where uh between dog and
person there is a relationship um that
has owner relationship so the domain is
dog a dog may have an owner which is a
person and this is all the schema level
and here you also have the data level
where Bob then where hustle is a dog
having an owner which is Bob which is a
person okay so very simple example
nothing very fancy about that when I
talk about this example please always
keep in mind this may directly be an rdf
data source or maybe you take an
established mapping of let's say a
relational data source into this very
simple kind of framework so there are is
for example this standard here R2 rml um
that was standardized like one and a
half years ago by w3c is the w3c
recommendation and in the meanwhile
there are very efficient mappers from
this relational world to this kind of
triple world uh when I mean with very
efficient um some colleagues like Hanan
sea uh from Texas they have execution
engines where doesn't basically make a
difference whether you then ask at this
triple level or whether you ask at the
original relation level so you can
really efficiently map between these
different
worlds the interesting part here is that
I will assume in the largest part of
this talk that I have a nice schema
description as I told you for the linked
open data Cloud that's not always true
some of the data do not have schema but
that's like the rest of my talk the very
end where we'll talk a little bit about
that how we can deal with this situation
when we don't don't have an explicit
schema description and also to make it
simple I don't talk about different
schema languages I just talk about this
schema language and this kind of data
level okay and that describes the agenda
of my talk I first want to talk about
given these assumptions how we can bring
these data sources into uh the FP
language and visual studio how can we
find out what is in an unknown data
source that's out there among these
hundreds of data sources that are out
there in this linked open data cloud or
that you encounter just by uh
integrating another part of your company
and integrating another data source that
you have not dealt with
before in the second uh part uh I want
to go a little bit into a very
preliminary user
evaluation uh I say very preliminary
because it has a couple of flaws that
that we are aware of but I think it
still shows a certain tendency uh of
what the approach watch does well and
what doesn't do so well yet and uh
eventually if I still have time I don't
know let's see um I want to talk a
little bit about our indexing approach
where we look at this huge cloud and we
need to find a particular piece of
information we want to find something
about creatures about dogs or persons
and of course this kind of information
may be spread all over the place not
just in a single data source and we
initially we may not know where it is
and then we have to look at um
querying such that we find the
corresponding data sources and then
explore them and integrate them and
program against them okay so let's start
with this first part where
we encounter some unknown data source
yeah just pick
your uh favorite one and then you want
to explore this data source and program
against the data that's available there
so I think that's quite a not so
uncommon scenario if you you do some
integration of different
databases and for the sake of making
this a little bit um better
understandable I don't go so much into
the formal definitions that we have in
in a tech report but rather just show it
more by example application here the
example application may be again taking
this tiny uh G toy example that I gave
that uh you may want to collect uh doc
license fees and want to send email
reminders to the doc owners and uh we
assume here that we have this nice kind
of graph again that I've shown you
before and you now have to do a couple
of tasks to solve this very simple um to
to do this very simple program so the
first task that you have to do as a
programmer yeah so as indicated here in
the title is to really explore the
schema and find out what is in this data
source yeah so you really assume you
don't know how the data is described
there and you encounter that
and you want to find the
types um that represent the data you're
interested in so of course you see
directly here on the slide that this may
be person and dog for example but of
course in general when you approach the
data source you just don't know whether
it's person or human whether it's dog or
canine or however the formulation might
be so you really need to look
around and classically this first task
you might do with a kind of a browser or
if you work in a semantic web you might
do a sparkle query and Sparkle is
another w3c recommendation that's around
for a couple of years now now um there's
like at least a second version of
Sparkle around and there are uh
different kind of engines that support
Sparkle uh support the the data format
of rdf in the background and you could
ask questions like give me all classes
where we have a subject that is of type
of particular class so you find all the
class there are around that have
instances by such a kind of a query and
you can do that but of course it's not
so easy to formulate the queries to
explore this kind of unknown data source
you easily get lost and if you are in a
situation that you say you start here
because that's uh the top class for all
the different classes it's not so easy
by asking these queries to navigate
through because every time you want to
do a refinement you have to completely
change the query
um so that would be like in a in a knif
approach you would you would still have
to do it like
this and um then when you have found out
okay I'm interested really in uh the do
and the person RF type well then of
course to program against that you
somehow have to mirror these kind of
types in your programming environment so
basically what you have to do you take
these kind of types and you provide code
types so
uh the the terminology always overlaps
here so I try to speak when I talk about
rdf of rdf types and when I talk about
FP for example I try to speak of code
types yeah so because both are of course
typing systems but the one is in your
data source and the other is in your
programming environment and you somehow
need to establish these type systems
both and you need to map between them
both right so you someh have to after
you've identified these as the the types
that you're interested in you have to
establish this code types in F sharp for
example so you might say something like
a creature is a certain class and while
it has a certain attributes like has
name and H H and um we then can have uh
subtypes like dog which would be another
coach type in FP or person and they
inherit all the attributes from Creature
um and in addition they may have further
attributes like the his owner um
property or maybe some text number for
the do or
so okay and that's the second task so
the programmer now has basically to
write this down which is actually much
of a copying task because the properties
are not really new they are already
given in the scheme of your data
source uh and next of course what you
have to do is you have to do data
querying so you won't query say I'm
interested in all Doc owners because I
want to remind them to um renew their
license for their dogs okay so what do
you have to do well once you have your
persons and dogs you are interested in
persons that are owners of dogs so you
may ask a sparkle query a knive approach
and just find these owners by putting
forward this kind of query all well
possible be aware that in general if
it's an unknown data source you don't
really know what these relations look
like what's their name and here they
even look nice uh and short but in
general these are very long unique
identifiers in the semantic web right so
or you may have long package names if
you U encounter a data source and not
just such a toy
example okay you have to write this
query and once you have this query of
course you have then to instantiate your
objects from these data source and
manipulate them and program against them
okay so you have to develop the
functionality around your query so
typically in F you would have to uh
formulate a query string this would be
for example this kind of Sparkle query
of shown you on the previous slide and
then you would evaluate this and then
you could um iterate over it to create
persons and send email reminders to them
um according to the emails that are
described um and that would be like the
four steps that I would identify here so
first exploring and understanding what's
in that data source then creating your
types in your programming environment
the the code types then querying your
data according to into that and
developing the functionality around that
and for that sort of like turning these
um data instances into code
object all quite nice and well but a
little bit laborious and the idea of
light CU was to say let's try to put
these different tasks together and
provide a kind of a framework that just
makes it easier for developer to handle
these tasks with fewer different tools
and fewer machinery and less uh boiler
plate code than uh we have so far yeah
and of course Behind these kind of ideas
you may already recognize if you think
of Link uh link q and of type providers
you you will see some of these ideas
shining through here again and we have
later on a comparison with regard to
these kind of uh
approaches now the co the core idea of
having these supporting these different
task is to have a kind of query language
which we call mql mql really is the not
paath query
language and it allows you to Traverse
the graph Traverse this rdf graph that
contains information about the schema
and contains information about the data
so the nice thing about rdf is that it
hardly distinguishes the two so they are
not really completely separate all of
them the schema information as well as
the data information is encoded in
triples and you can ask for these
triples using
Sparkle and nql is just like a and you
could say syntactic sugar to formulate
your sparkle queries in a way that makes
it easier for the developer to go
through these different tasks with the
same kind of the syntax and not having
completely different syntaxes all the
time for this language we have then
developed three different kind of
semantics right so you want to to just
go through this graph that's the the
exploration part but then you want to
query for data and for that well we have
have some typical extensional semantics
no big surprise here yeah that's just
what you would expect and then we have
also thought well we don't not only want
to have the extension that is all the
data that follow a certain pattern but
we really also don't want to duplicate
the types that we have in that system
there so what we then defined is an
intentional semantics for basically the
same kind of queries that gives you back
these type descriptions so you don't
have to reinvent these type descriptions
because just query for them and then you
sort of like can put them together with
the extension sematics I will show you
in a minute how this works and once you
have that you can actually not only use
that for nicely writing your code but
you can even suggest to the developer
what next to write and that's what I
call here autocompletion semantics so
when writing these kind of queries you
are supported all the time with
particular suggestions of what could fit
fill into your query language at a
particular point in time so let me again
show these different types of semantics
and tasks by examples so the first thing
would be to say you want to uh explore
this graph so you
start uh let's say with RF resource and
then you have an operator here for
subtype navigation and then you go to
creature so you change from this context
to this context you go from one note in
the graph to another note in the
graph um this can become a little bit
more complicated you can start also a
different point of view uh a different
point a different note in the graph so
you would start here with dog and then
uh you navigate along a property not
very surprisingly navigating over has
owner you land at the prison
node and now we can Define what happens
then if we um Define the extensional
semantics for that well assume we are
for example here at the the dog node we
have navigated there from the top class
down to creature down to dog we have by
this means selected doc as our current
context for
evaluation we can walk through the has
owner relationship by this dot
operator and well then we can just
extensionally evaluate what this query
means so this query is it looks almost
like n path query with a little bit
different operators um and then you just
say I'm now interested in all the notes
that fulfill these conditions and if you
think in terms of you have been here at
this dog and you have navigated bya this
has owner relationship to person you use
the extension to retrieve all persons
who own dogs because that's the context
from which you came and you end up here
with Bob because Bob in this example is
the owner of
hustle Okay so so we have seen we
explore this path and then we say we're
interested in what are the kind of
objects that fit my description as I was
walking along the
graph now it becomes interesting I mean
Y when you said that there's not much
distinction between data and schema does
that mean if if my query had been
instead like resource to creature and
then ask and then follow do uh subass I
would get all schema elements that are
subclasses of
creature um or do you have to get down
into the data before you can use so the
extensional semantics here always looks
them for the instances what you could
easily do here is you could do
metamodeling yeah and in fact actually
rdf has some metamodel approach so this
for example creature is a subass of
resource but it's also an instance of
the rdfs class
yeah yeah so you could walk from
resource to rdfs class and then say with
an extensional query give me the
extension of rdfs class and to the
extension of rdfs class creature would
belong yeah so RFS has this meta
modeling kind of thing and uh thanks for
asking a question I forgot to mention
initially please interrupt me all the
time um when you're interested in a
particular explanation I think that's
better um yeah so that's easily possible
and remember see here again this kind of
query for which we when where we look
for the extension we can do the same
kind of query so navigate to dog
and um then to the owner so that's the
same kind of query as before and that
basically means we're interested in
some persons here like Bob but now if we
ask for ttention that means we do not
look for Bob but we rather look for the
intentional description of the people
down
here right so this expression Now does
not any longer refer to the instances
like Bob who are owners of dogs but
because we look at the intention it
looks at how can we describe the type of
these
instances right and obviously this type
has all the attributes of
person so this means that by using the
same kind of query expression we first
get the instances and with the same kind
of query only the last operator is
different we get the schema description
of these instances which we may then use
very nicely for creating our F Type
description yeah so we can now say in FP
using this kind of
query I want to describe oops sorry it's
just old version uh here it should
describe actually the person class being
returned here and um I have not updated
this properly and then you would just
appear what has been retrieved according
to the
intention the thing being here is that
once you have formulated this query you
can then build this into your
environment and say please give me the
objects and type them at the same
time
um and you can use the same kind of
thing for the exploration so here we
have a query that says I want to go from
resource to creature from here to here
and then it depends on what kind of
operators you use I only given a partial
account here of The Operators but let's
say if you look for subass
navigation this actually this expression
here would not be um complete expression
according to our query
description because it really looks here
for uh another class description or
class term I would should rather say but
what we can do here now is that based on
the context up to here and based on this
kind of operator we can suggest what
would be
appropriate um next terms to fill into
this place so what we basically do here
at this point is we Define these autoc
completion semantics and do
suggestions and we do suggestions
depending on the
operators um there are some operators
that look then for instances Martin will
show you one of them uh in the demo and
then the instances we derive using the
extensional semantics of this expression
plus some further information or we can
look at types and
properties and we derive the properties
or types that may be appropriate in such
a situation here would be the
types according to the intentional
description of the preceding query
expression okay so here obviously when
we look for creature we may then look at
well what are the sub classes of that
creature and suggest uh both dog and
person uh would be appropriate sub
classes and these are suggested because
these are the direct sub classes to uh
the programmer who writes his code um to
complete his
query um these are just some some of the
features just one feature to give you a
little bit the flavor of uh what light C
is about is a um a little bit more
complicated query not a lot more
complicated but a tiny bit um and what
it does here is to say if you start at
do we may be interested not just in all
the dogs because there may be dogs with
without owners and we cannot then uh
have some license fee for them if they
don't have owners but we can only have
license fees if there are owners and uh
then we can restrict the set of these
dos to those dos that have owners right
and this would be a corresponding query
for doing exactly that uh if some of you
are familiar with description Logics are
some of you have you encountered
description Logics before it's a subset
of first order Logics and this is very
much actually like uh a concept
description in description Logics where
you then can look at such expressions
and ask for instances of such a complex
concept and where you can also do kind
of query
subsumption and that's what we are uh
aiming at here and of course in this
context the dogs that have owners this
would include hustle if there would be
another dog without an owner that would
not be returned
here yeah it's a very restricted form of
querying it's not giving you the full
Sparkle support right it's very much
focused traversing the graph and
restricting the number of notes that
you're
encountering so it's would call it here
left associative conjunctive query you
cannot build arbitrary queries by this
way in Sparkle you have like full power
for all kind of conjunctive queries and
more we don't have that here but that's
by Design at this point in time because
we really want to support the developer
in writing these kind of queries and in
suggesting to him what would be
appropriate schema information
properties um classes or even then the
data level instances to complete his
query and to work with that right so we
didn't Target um a full query language
like SQL link linku or um spark hle so
but rather a subset of
that
so we had now the exploration task you
see you have also seen how this would be
supported with autoc completion we have
the type definition task using the
intentional semantics we have the query
task being supported with extensional
semantics and the fourth task that I
mentioned before in a naive way was to
create objects and manipulate them and
make them persistent right so you want
to get the objects from your data source
you want to work with them and then also
um give the results back to the data
source and of course for that you have
to develop functionality around the
query
um and if we look at how we can do this
here this would just mean okay just
first some some boiler plate code like
including our uh light Q mechanism then
you have to define the data source in
the future we will think about how to go
from one data source to another data
source in the uh linked open data web
but but right now it's just like you
have to indicate where exactly this one
source
is and then you write here your query so
given this data source write a query for
example for creature navigating down to
dock navigating to has owner so the
operators look a little bit different
than I've shown you in the more slightly
more formal part uh but they do exactly
the same and so what you get here is are
the stock
owners and
then you can just take these stock
owners and iterate over them and for
example send them the email reminder so
the nice thing here is you directly get
here this uh extensional semantics and
in this assignment you also assign the
types to these doc
owners it's not just that you have some
arbitrary data objects here these data
objects are typed uh with at least
person and also with the hierarchy above
person including the creature so you can
use here then in this expression um also
like the information from um from the
creature class which had the name
attribute for example or the age
attribute we have a preliminary
implementation of this approach um
supporting FP uh so this is the website
it's really preliminary so it's not
really anything like productive code it
it's good enough to look at the basic
idea and we know quite a couple of
things we have to do to make it uh
usable in a in a productive environment
that will still take us a couple of
weeks uh but it's good enough to to take
a look and see uh what's the the
principle behind and I would now suggest
that we switch over to Martin who will
uh show you some demo of the system as
it is
now and uh so we'll switch over the
screens
and also hand over for explanation to
you uh yes so what we will do we will
actually query the data store
um and uh well a very simple cross qu
would be
to would be to uh gr for all dogs
which looks like
this um you know in this case we
actually start one step below uh RF
resource because RF resource is always
there um so we start at creature and
basically the the data source behind it
is exactly the same as we've shown you
before on the schema so we go to
creature we do a subtype navigation and
choose dog
and get the extension and then we can do
something like print out the names of
all
dogs
uh get name
no and if we run this we hopefully get a
list of all docs that are in our data
source
um right now it's um well as as Stefan
mentioned before we're just uh
using uh rdf
schema um that's why you will always get
a a basic basically a list of
possibilities back like here sequence or
list that just contains the string hasso
or Bellow because you can't really
restrict uh the number of triples in the
schema so we have to assume that there
are always
more
um yeah so like this you could get all
dogs and then you could also go on a
individual level so you could say uh
show me all individual of
dogs
and luckily there are only two ones in
our data source so let's choose
Bellow and we want to actually get an
object so we can work with
Bellow and we can
now also print out the text number of
him this is very interesting the Dos of
tax
numbers so uh that's sort of a lit
German translation so we I had to look
it up actually so that you would say
license fee number or something like
that I don't
know it's German
example
differ
or false friend among the different
words all right so um the text number of
hle is 1 2 3 4 so we can now go ahead
and change that and you see this get
text number that's support because we
know the type of Bell right that helps
us here to to show the right kind of
properties that's again typing
information
have you thought
about having some operators that would
be less ugly
than individual yes we we definitely
thought about it um this was just uh a
first intuition you know we we wanted to
um we were excited to get started and
this
was the first thing that came to mind
one thing I mean the first idea was also
had the kind of operators that I showed
you before on the slide but we are the
implementation reuses the type provider
mechanism yeah uh in FP and there we
have to misuse currently when we use
that this kind of notation so because
the dot notation already means something
in the type providers we were not
completely flexible in choosing the
grammar uh would we choose the grammar
arbitrarily we would go for something
closer to the uh version I had on the on
the slides actually um we're trying to
look into dsls in F in the future and
try to explore a bit uh in in this
direction um but we're also open to
other suggestions so if anybody has a
good pointer we're happy
um yeah so we just changed the uh text
number of bellow and this will be
persisted in the store so if we want it
again it will still be the new text
number and in the background basically
all these um queries or manipulations
are translated to Sparkle queries and
and Sparkle updates so basically we
don't care
about what kind of store is run in the
background as long as it's Sparkle
compatible could you show if I didn't
know where dog was in the hierarchy do
you have a a way to
uh well you search the data context for
any
um right now in this implementation you
would need to go down the hierarchy
you're right now really forced to start
at creature which is a a huge limitation
right now in in this
implementation um the only good thing is
that the autoc completion can you know
help you in finding your type but
conceivably all the individuals under
creature like Bell exists under creature
that individuals yeah you could also do
that but it doesn't go upward it doesn't
go up the class Hier no I mean we could
do that actually in our first draft we
had operators for that then we wanted to
keep it simple first get the first
version going I mean it's still a middle
of the project it's not like finished
yeah know I think about when people get
data right the first thing you want to
do is like see it right when you get a
SE absolutely select star you know St
100 star so I think that exploratory
nature is and well the next thing we
would have to to do we will have to do
there is uh you can do in Sparkle limits
like you can do in SQL 2 uh so you don't
get like millions of individuals because
doesn't make sense right the 100 I
assume is a limit in your typeid
parameter yes that's so is tradeoff that
you're running against which is the type
for a rider
framework and the under data which is
huge yes
yeah that's I mean in the end it's
always problematic if you go to the or
if you would query dbpedia and and would
try to use individuals you would just
get overwhelmed by the result and you
have actually more than one way to
arrive at dock because you can do uh
arrive there by going down the hierarchy
but you can also cross navigate right
like you've seen that with person we
could navigate from Creature to person
we can also go to dog and then say who
who are the owners so we'd also arrive
at person so there are different
possibilities to arrive at the same
types uh because you really have a graph
that's also a major difference to the
usual type provider approaches where you
rather have a tree um to in your your
exploration so the tree is basically
going down for example a certain
hierarchy and then you may have some
data at the leaves of that tree that's a
typical way the um freebased type
provider for example
works but here we have this this graph
which also makes it a bit more
complicated to sort of like arrange all
the
interaction um with the auto completion
engine okay all
right so we switch back to uh the slide
deck um I have here a comparison with
different kind of approaches that also I
think tells you a little bit about uh um
how I well we would compare the approach
first link Q well link Q is of course
very good at querying for the data and
then also manipulating the objects you
have to Define your types yourself in
order then to use them and to work them
with these uh program expressions and of
course well you don't have the schema
exploration
part um but working with the the objects
and querying you have here the full
expressiveness for light CU we have here
two columns uh one column is sort of
like what we plan to have in the end and
the other column is what we have now um
that's of course not yet the full uh
thing so um even here in the end we will
not have full Sparkle for example so it
would not be as powerful in quering as
Sparkle or not be as powerful as
querying like link q but that's like
this trade-off where we really want to
support the user in writing queries and
be able to type them automatically right
if we don't require this automatic
typing we can come with more complex
queries if you don't want to do the
autoc completion or if you do auto
completion in a very different way
that's another thing we're discussing
now how to better support Auto
completion for Sparkle then we would not
have this kind of restriction well we
only have a subset of The Operators that
we have in our concept yet and if you
look to something like the freebased
type provider you have some sort of data
querying but it's much much much more
restricted than even what we have now in
uh light Q
okay well here you have two kind of type
providers of course it depends how the
different type providers are implemented
so it's a little bit difficult to say
the type provider mechanism is like this
because it really depends on the
implementation so we have indicated here
two different type providers uh one for
XML and one for free base so for example
the schema exploration that happens in
type provider and was which was also
sort of like the uh motivation for us to
do a kind of exploration um well sorry
just try to make sure we have Apple
staff comparison here when you say link
what exactly are you referring to just
the just the query API level inside the
runtime um or are you referring to
trying to have connectivity to an actual
persistence
store not sure where you draw the line
there I mean what you have here with
link is you have certain possibilities
for doing type inference because you
don't have the query Expressions uh as
strings but you really have them as code
in your program yes and uh uh you have
of course all the possibilities for
doing the querying in your program code
director when you say link what is the
data
source well it depends of course what
what you query with whether it's XML or
whether it's relational which is why I'm
wondering what the column actually means
so for instance If instead of link you
put in Entity framework which is a link
provider then you get number two
possibly get number one okay I was not
aware of this but we should look this up
yeah thanks for for that's called entity
Entity framework Entity framework okay I
was not aware of
that okay now I was thinking of here of
XML and the
relational
yeah um yeah so for XML type providers
um you have schema exploration but for
example it's restricted here to trees
but the information also in free base is
not restricted actually to trees so
that's why I even sort of indicated it's
not like the full exploration of
everything um Cod type
creation including our current
version um uses erased types so for
these eras erase types the types are
used at design time for doing the aut
completion but then they're thrown away
and that has also some negative
consequence on our current
implementation we don't have the full
possibility to do a switch based on the
type of an object at runtime that's
something we would like to have right so
that's where we want to go here and have
real full types and the full hierarchy
um but that's not part of the type
hierarchy mechanism as it is now um here
I was not quite sure so that's why I put
the question mark but we believe it's
also rise types but we did not do a full
investigation um and for data querying
yeah so here free Bas type provider
basically are ask then for the instances
of a particular class if you have the
country class and you get all the
instances of that you would of course
get all the countries uh but not much
more and uh once we have the full types
not just the erase types we can also do
um new object Creations currently we
can't do that so what we can do right
now is really to uh take the objects as
Martin has shown you and manipulate some
attributes but what we would also like
to do is say okay here are these types
like uh docs from the RF data source
make me a new object and also make it
persistent um in the data source and uh
that's currently not possible so we we
we don't have that right now but I think
once we have the full types that should
be easy enough to implement so that's a
um rough uh comparison to some of the
related
work um there's a lot to do now for
light Q so so the current implementation
as I mentioned is a prototype I just
mentioned this erased type problem
um we need to do some optimizations with
the code to have a full Las evaluation
which we currently don't have we also
want to better analyze which types are
really needed just at design time and
which are really needed at runtime so we
can be um sparsely add types to the
programming framework and we at least
also now we don't throw all the types
into the um into the the
dll um but I think we can do some more
optimizations there to make a more finer
gra distinction what we also still need
to do and have not yet done because it's
really just in the middle of the the
project is to really look exactly
precisely at our query language and its
expressiveness and uh how it compares to
other kind of approaches and in
particular one thing that I think really
interesting
uh which goes a little bit also be
beyond our uh scope uh because we are
mostly at home here in this data
modeling world looking at RF we had
quite some projects where we did
modeling with uml class diagrams meta
modeling and this kind of thing and we
can use description Logics to explain a
lot of that and the queries on that what
I think really interesting is then to
look at the program programming world
and have type inference as you have an F
or in ml and then see how these kind of
types that are derived at hoc where we
have dogs that have owners these are
kind of description Logics like types
that are then put into a lce of
different types in the data source
description how this mechanism would
interact with type inference you have in
your programming World um where you then
derive new types and I think that will
probably be a non-trivial behavior how
these different lesses interact and this
could mean that you have new objects for
example new object that you have created
that you can place at a lower point in
the hierarchy in the data source or you
may have more refined for example static
analysis of your types in the
programming world because you have all
this type hierarchy that you take from
the data
source so it's a little bit speculation
here but that's one of the research tar
um aims that we have
there so let me come to a little bit of
the evaluation of light
Q um
we thought about how can we and it's
it's really a tentative evaluation I
would not sort of like want to say it's
it's really like uh good enough to
submit this to a software engineering
conference for example but it's like
indicating a little bit where um where
the problems are and also like where the
advantages are so first we looked at how
can we evaluate light C at all and then
determine that the process as a whole is
a little bit hard to evaluate for
various reasons because it's hard to see
what would be the the
counterpart and also we had practical
problems for example we we used well
people from The Institute and so on but
um there we didn't have so many test
subjects that would know FP or even just
like functional programming very well so
it would be quite difficult to come up
with a fair
evaluation um so we decided to rather
compare only mql against
Sparkle and with the hypothesis being
that mql with it Auto completion allows
for Effective query writing while being
more efficient when compared against
Sparkle right and that of course means
this is a very focused evaluation that
even does not use some of the advantages
of light Q because it really goes only
into the exploration part and the data
querying part and not for example in
reusing um the queries for doing
programming than in task four where code
functionality um I against it so we had
participants while we actually
afterwards eliminated one subject
because the subject would not be able to
handle Sparkle at all he was able to
handle nql but not Sparkle uh but we
thought it then too unfair to sort of
like include his times so we still had
10 subjects remaining for analysis well
students undergrad students PhD students
few
posts um the setup was to have a
pre-questionnaire about their knowledge
to have a
classification uh give them a little bit
of training in rdf and Sparkle in case
they needed that and also nql which of
course was new for all of them and U
then we had some tasks for them to solve
and a post questionnaire about what they
liked and what they disliked so here is
a little bit of insight into that
evaluation routine we looked at well who
what were the programming skills well
all were either classified themselves as
intermediate programmers or better uh
object orientation eight of them would
say there are intermediate or are better
in that uh functional programming only
four would say they're intermediate or
above four would say they have no
knowledge about functional programming
when we looked at functional programming
there are Lis and
hasal most of mentioned F was mentioned
once here and we looked at uh net how
would they know the framework then be
able to work in this uh environment so
uh we had one expert two beginners and
seven who didn't has had not encountered
net yet and then we looked at Sparkle
there were
three um individuals that said they
would be would have intermediate
knowledge or above for
Sparkle and we classified them in the
next slides as Sparkle experts and seven
had uh indicated less than intermediate
so we would classify them here as
Sparkle
novices then we had a training phase
about 20 minutes live presentation by uh
Martin and uh another PhD student Stefan
shelman and indicated
U to Sparkle queries and let them work
with the environment to write Sparkle
queries um so give them a little bit ad
hoc training just 5 minutes and also 5
minutes for mpq queries and writing them
in the visual studio environment so that
would basically know how to operate um
the corresponding
tools there were nine different tasks to
solve half of the tasks we split them up
in two
groups um and the one group would have
half of the task in Sparkle and the
other half of npq and the other group
was just reversed so you just would uh
not have a bias towards the one or the
other kind of tasks uh half the tasks
were done using ual Studio the other
half using Sparkle and the web interface
you you had actually seen the web
interface before on some of the slides
very simple web interface and the task
types were really there
to explore well how well can you
navigate and explore the data so it's
corresponding to the programmer's task
one of finding what the source is the
source was very small yeah just like 50
facts so it was not a big big task yet
where you had thousands of uh schema
elements and tens of thousands of of
effects or so so was that intentional I
mean I guess you was it because you
couldn't find a source is because a big
Source was no finding a big source is
not a problem oh okay okay so why didn't
you use a larger Source uh this is a
kind of preliminary trial and there's
also still the stuff that we have to do
about optimization to deal with large
number of facts impact on the
performance impact
yeah we will have that uh I don't I'm
not concerned about that but right now
when we did that this was uh not quite
the case and then retrieving answering
questions about the data task three and
we also included two tasks that were
intentionally not solvable by mpq I
mentioned to you that some of the tasks
you just cannot do because you cannot
count for example and so um we we
wondered how uh what people would do or
when they would back off and say okay I
cannot do that um so that was by
intention
design and well we took the durations to
task
completion okay so here is I think the
the interesting part um again don't take
these numbers too seriously it was still
like a pre-trial it was not like a full
enough formula so so the numbers lie a
bit uh but the tendency was really that
the sparkle novices really appreciated
support by mql the sparkle experts did
not benefit so much even if you compare
this number against that they was a
little bit slack because they were
starting to talk about what um were the
advantages disadvantages and it's was
not a fully formalized trial yet so that
will be the next step so it's rather
really tentative
results we have to be a little bit
careful about these numbers but it shows
you a little bit the effect that if
people are really familiar with sparkle
um they they would not gain quite as
much but the other ones for them it was
way simpler to to deal with
it and and well the unsolvable tasks
then really they gave uh people problems
uh just to find out they couldn't solve
it for this you need to understand what
you can do and what you can't do here is
an evaluation per task so nine different
tasks the gray ones were
unsolvable and then you see there's
typically um the the average is a little
bit better for uh mql overall but there
were also more novices here than Sparkle
experts so how did you find completion
have an unsolvable test is it it was
really just taking the duration it was
uh so so this will be the next try we
have to to to just do a a cut off at
five minutes or so I see yeah and
eventually what they did it was for
example a task it was a small fact base
so when we asked like um how many docks
are there uh they could just return all
the dogs and count them by hand that
would be allowed
Tech but they could not directly say
count me the number of dogs right which
you can do in Sparkle
right and of course it also means that
only with small fact base that's really
possible right when you then have a
million of dogs and then enough time
yeah recogniz that it was not solvable
with the you know with the npq basically
yeah that would be a question some of
them did actually some of them said okay
I cannot I cannot count so so I'm going
to write here not solvable others just
took it as it is and and count it
without any comment and wrot the number
down and a point of course is I mean you
can always make the language more
complex but at some point you will have
you will lose this functionality of
getting the types yeah and so that's
that's a kind of trade-off point which
we still need to explore better and
understand this uh better in a formal
way and uh then in the post
questionnaire we asked this question
well do you really want to expl explor
data source in your um development
environment four of them said yes three
three actually said no so maybe it's not
for all of them maybe some would rather
say I don't care about that just um and
three didn't have a a clear
preference so as opposed to what you
know well you can of course just have a
browser you can have a browser where you
wander around you get a nice graph and
there are browsers like that around and
uh then you just uh
switch to your IDE and and program
it I think part of that was also because
like the IDE still was too slow really
so I think when that becomes faster I
think that numbers will also change a
bit but still it's still remarkable that
um some didn't like or didn't need it so
much uh nql is easier to use than
Sparkle well seven of them would agree
to
that um
but well there's still one needs also
better support when writing Sparkle
queries so basically there's
no good Sparkle query writing support
right now and we're looking into this
question as well because that would also
help of course um it's not so
straightforward because you have so many
dimensions which you can continue a
query once you have written one line
that it's not obvious at all how to do
that if you have a large set of queries
that people have already asked the query
source then of course you can do
recommendations but if you don't have
that it's not quite clear uh what to
do um and then better response times so
that's one of the tasks we have to work
on now my conclusion is tentative
conclusion that light Q is still in
pre-alpha status we see some
advantages um and of course once you
handle things better then uh some of
that result will become stronger I I
think okay so we have how much more time
do we have so you have about 20 minutes
20 minutes okay so I can I can talk a
little bit about my third
part we have now this framework for
looking at an unknown data source
exploring it querying against it but the
problem of course may be how to find
this data source in the first place
right and uh that's what the last part
is about about schex constructing an
index uh such that you can determine
where to find certain information and
also then induce a schema if you only
have facts and that's happening quite
often with the semi-structured data
sources so here would be a typical
example you're interested for example in
some set of documents that appeared in
some conference proceedings written by a
computer scientist and you would have a
sparkle query for that so that's a
sparkle query you're interested some X
of type document of type impr
proceedings where there's some creator
that is a computer
scientist
and you have the link data cloud and you
want to find out where do you find such
piece of information right
um if what we do is we compute an
index and uh then can answer this
question which for example would say
here in the link data Cloud there is an
ACM data source mirroring the
bibliographic metadata of ACM uh digital
library and there's dblp is one of the
other data source and there are some
more but here these are two that you
could ask so what do you need to do then
to order to query them we need you need
schema information you need to know
where data conforming to this or that
schema would be around and we need to
look at two types of schema information
first we need explicit schema
information
an entity for example may be directly
assigned to a class so in the example I
assigned this variable to the class uh
document and to the class in proceedings
that's an explicit assignment but
actually what you will see often and
there are a couple of papers out there
now in the semantic web community that
uh looked at implicit information so
quite often there's more schema
information in how any entities are
related to each other than in the
assignment to classes but it's not
always clear so there's variance in
there some some data sources it's really
like the class information is dominating
some data sources it's really more
information about the schema but just by
looking at the data items and how they
are related to each
other and
uh yeah so the schema level index that
we then
built is for entities and these entities
are maybe related to particular classes
types they may be related to other
entities other classes and may be
related to Strings integers and other
kind of building data
types and the idea is of course to say
well we have certain structures and we
can map these structures to determine
that in data source one two or whatever
we find entities that conform to this
schema
structure so what do we do well one is
to say that we have type clusters type
clusters are combinations of classes
that appear together so do we
have let's say a president that also was
an actor right so you would have a type
cluster uh for this kind of uh entities
and you would then say for such a type
cluster where in your different data
sources your hundreds of data sources
you have entities that fall into uh two
or three or four of these
classes now here we are interested in
documents and proceedings and we
interested in the type cluster and we
find that in dblp and in ASM we both
have entities that fall into this type
cluster um
then we have entities and we say they're
equivalent if they refer to the same
attributes to equivalent other
entities and what we do here is we
compute one bu simulation so if you have
a little bit back ground in XML schema
induction people like ab and so computer
data guides and uh in order to come up
with a schema description of XML
documents that don't have an explicit
schema uh description and here what we
we do a likewise thing we restrict it to
one by simulation if you do arbitrary bi
simulation you may run into difficulties
with regard to the complexity but here
we just look into uh for such a
description what are the kind of
properties that appear together for the
entities and then we say okay these
property combinations they appear in
certain data sources for example if you
look at Creator then we would find that
for example the BBC um metadata uh but
also the dblp metadata includes this
Creator
property and then we can combine this
together with restrictions on the
destination so we say we have an
equivalence class that's built by
looking at a type cluster like document
and in proceedings and a restriction
according to one by simulation looking
at the different properties like Creator
and that is restricted not to an
arbitrary creator for example it could
be restricted to an creator that is of
type
person other Creator might be of type
organization or something like that and
then we find something that belongs into
this class in these different data
sources right and so we have then here a
schema description
that's induced by a combination of
looking at the different classes that
entities have together with different
properties that this entity has have and
their range
types and of course the next step for us
to do is that if we have data with
little explicit schema information we
use this kind of schema induction in
order to present it in the F environment
and say here look that's the type that
you can reuse and then here you have to
payload the actual data sources out
there on the web uh that you can query
for this kind of
data so if you look at document and in
proceedings we have a type cluster we
can build an equivalence class from this
type cluster and from The Bu simulation
that restricts Creator to computer
scientists and then see that only in
dblp we have this kind of information
because the BBC does not have stuff that
was created by computer scientists I
believe okay and then when you then have
a sparkle query you can look at exactly
this kind of structural information in
order to derive that you should rather
ask dblp than any of the other data
sources to find entities of that
kind um we can precisely compute how
this looks like with we were then
wondering about exploiting uh principles
of locality for one thing we did was to
look at uh streams of data that come in
to say that when we we parse the data
they're out there on the link data web
we don't need to look at the full
payload but even if you look just look
at parts we get rather good quality so
we do rather computation that's
restricted to a piece of memory that we
can handle easily and we looked at uh
empirically at how well this works and
we find that actually even with rather
um small cash sizes of just like um 100K
and so on we end up with rather good
values for precision and for recall so
we lose a little bit but we don't lose
too much even with rather small cash
sizes and that was actually also
something we presented two years ago and
at the billion triple uh challenge so
the semantic web conference always has
these kind of challenges also for
handling large data was much appreciate
appreciated it because with the kind of
Hardware we could handle this very
efficiently give us a first place so
that concludes this part we still need
to explore further the schema induction
part the query Federation based on these
structures one thing that we were
intensively discussing also Inu tool
seminar last summer was how to handle
the querying of data in length data web
there are two main approaches right now
one is a very fine grain one you always
ask a
URI give me your description you ask the
individual object you can do that it's
easy to publish that but if you want to
do this for many objects it just does
not scale because you have too many
messages there's the other very
expressive one where you open up your
data source to arbitrary Sparkle queries
it's very expressive you can ask select
star and you get everything or do all
kind of interesting restrictions but
it's not a very stable solution at least
right now the sparkle end points are not
very stable and of course it pro costs
you a lot if people do arbitrary queries
so we we were even discussing whether
something like a restricted query
language whether it's mql or something
in this direction might be quite a nice
trade-off between being too fine grained
um costing too many queries and too many
Network messages uh and something which
is too expressive like sparkling costs
you too much but it's still an ongoing
discussion
and that brings me to my last slide what
is the future of these kind of
approaches in general what or what we
look at is to look at like searching for
distributed data would of course also
include stuff like keyword IND and stuff
we had in other systems with it but not
and what I describ today to understand
this distribute data and there are a few
papers out there now from our group from
uh uh two or three other groups that
look at what does it mean
to look at statistics of
this rdf data structure to derive schema
to understand what are the important
properties most properties that are
allowed according to the schema are not
filled so you have also zip like
distribution of how these properties are
used you can look at schema.org stuff
that's supported by Bing supported by
Google and uh these properties are not
like uniformly used over the different
sites and well then of course formulate
intelligent queries I mean the one query
indicated now for schic was other still
a very fixed one where you know exactly
what properties you're looking for that
will not always be the case and program
against the distributed data and that's
something which is rather ignored in the
semantic web Community up to now but
then may be quite nice if you want to
bring this community on board because
it's a pain really to uh write string
based queries that are very brittle and
where you don't have type safety and and
all the things and we hope that our kind
of approach helps in this direction so
thank you for your
attention there is
any other
question you have act slides on what the
tasks that used for the service so we
have some more information on the web
page um I think are the individual
questions also there I'm not sure I'm
not sure um we should put them there was
the
plan um let me see but definitely you
can explore more on this web page and uh
if something is missing from there just
send me an email and uh we'll provide it
to you in the one or the other
way um here that was the web
page all right thank you thanks
thanks